[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance try to impeach him Roger
stone said quoting again just try it you
will have a spasm of violence and
insurrection in this country like you
have never seen both sides are heavily
armed this is stone who publicly boasted
of his connection to two of the
individuals involved in disseminating
the emails stolen from his candidate
selection opponent dog whistling for
what the interviewer asked him Civil War
yes he answered about Civil War quote
that is what I think will happen people
will not stand for impeachment stone
continued a politician who votes for it
would be endangering their own life here
again a dog whistle
this time for assassination then the
pitiful disclaimer quoting there will be
violence on both sides let me make this
clear I'm not advocating violence but I
am predicting it these are the arguments
against the House and Senate fulfilling
its responsibilities and duties as
described in the Constitution of the
United States the arguments as presented
by the former senior advisor to Donald
Trump's presidential campaign his
arguments which can be summarized as I'm
not calling for killing congressmen and
Senators I'm just saying if any of them
dare to try to impeach the president
they could be killed oh and if they do
impeach him his supporters will start a
civil war this is mentioned now about a
week after stones said it for several
reasons firstly because it is incumbent
on all of us to understand that this is
how many of trumps true believers think
secondly because it is important to note
that having raised this doomsday
scenario of violence insurrection and
civil war stone refused to take the
opportunity to disavow it or even to
discourage it thirdly because stone has
apparently forgotten that if Trump were
impeached and removed he and his quote
side would no longer have control of the
military and the rebellion and civil war
stone fantasizes about
would be a very brief and a very losing
one and fourthly because stone has
apparently not been noticing the little
bud of green that has poked itself up
from this manure pile of a presidency
namely when the impeachment process gets
serious much of the president's cabinet
may join it pressed about international
rebuked for Trump's racist response to
Charlottesville Secretary of State
Tillerson defended his department he
defended all the other departments he
defended the American people he defended
our commitment to freedom he defended
our commitment to equal rights and when
Chris Wallace of Fox News asked and the
president's values Tillerson sternly
answered the president speaks for
himself Chris and when Wallace then
asked are you separating yourself from
that sir Tillerson sternly answered
I've spoken I've made my own comments as
to our values as well in a speech I gave
to the State Department this past week
secretary Tillerson is many things but
he is not the kind of man who would not
have realized that speaking on the only
network champions believe is not fake
he had twice refused to defend the
President of the United States speaking
extemporaneously to troops apparently in
Jordan Secretary of Defense mattis told
them quote you're buying time you're a
great example for our country right now
it's got some problems you know it and I
know it it's got problems that we don't
have in the military you just hold the
line until our country gets back to
understanding and respecting each other
and showing it and being friendly to one
another
secretary mattis's many things but he is
not the kind of man who would have
thought his comments would not have
gotten back to this country after the
pardoning of Joe Arpaio's somebody
apparently in the Justice Department or
in the White House or both revealed that
even before our payos case went to trial
this year Trump had asked Attorney
General Jeff Sessions to drop the case
against our pal The Washington Post had
three sources quote with knowledge of
the conversation and the press secretary
then all but confirmed that conversation
attorney general sessions and those
around him are men
things but they are not the kind of
people who would have thought the leak
would not be traced back to them the
list goes on and on Republican senators
and congressmen finally speaking out
against Trump on Charlottesville on our
pay Oh on the response to hurricane
Harvey on the Secretary of the Treasury
watching the Eclipse while standing next
to 200 billion dollars in gold on the
military transgender ban the daughter of
the Secretary of the Interior herself a
veteran calling for his impeachment over
that a web site run by a Republican
research firm noting with Sporn that in
one month Trump had attacked nearly one
out of every seven Republican senators
the little tendrils are popping up
through the soil so well fertilized by
seven months of this administration and
the president of [ __ ]
Roger stones insurrection may in fact be
coming to pass except it will be
nonviolent and when it is over it will
not be good news for stone or his fellow
travelers and when it ends there will
not be Trump resist remove peace PS the
book of these commentaries and my other
writings on Trump will come out October
17th
you can pre-order it now or don't or
just wait for the movie or something